(bêlement)
- C'était il y a 25 ans, en
Écosse. Une avancée scientifique
qui avait frappé l'imaginaire.
La naissance de Dolly,
le premier mammifère issu
du clonage d'une cellule adulte.
Le Moalalalais Lawrence Smith
a contribué à cet exploit.
Il ne s'attendait toutefois pas
à un si grand intérêt du public.
ENENENCE SMITH, Dép. biomédecine
vétérinaire, U. de Montréal
- Je n'avais pas vu vraiment,
comme... la réaction,
comment elle est venue
d'une façon aussi forte.
- Dolly a été clonée grâce à la
technique de transfert nucléaire
de cellules somatiques.
Les chercheurs ont prélevé une
cellule de la brebis, en ont
extrait le noyau et le matériel
génétique, puis ont implanté ce
noyau dans un ovule non fécondé.
Quelques mois plus tard :
une nouvelle brebis, presque
identique à la première.
Rapidement, les implications
de cette découverte fascinen
le public. Et une question
s'impose : pourrait-on cloner
un être humain en utilisant
le même procédé?
- C'est clair que c'est possible
de le faire chez l'h
Il n'y a aucune barrière
biologique.
- Peu de temps après la
naissance de Dolly, les Raéliens
affirment avoir réussi.
- Apparemment, elle a réussi du
premier  j j j j je puis dire.
- Il s'agissait finalement
d'un canular. Et rien n'indique
qu'un être humain ait été
cloné depuis.
D'autres mammifères, en
revanche, l'ont été : vaches,
chiens, cochons, souvent
à des fins commerciales.
À St-Hyacinthe, par exemple, le
célèbre taureau Starbuck avait
été cloné pour cette raison.
Mais aujourd'hui, ce n'est pas
tant le clonage qui intéresse
les scientifiques que
la recherche en génétique.
Cellules souches, technologie
CRISPR, la science a
beaucoup évolué depuis Dolly.
À McGill, un centre de recherche
en a fait sa spécialité.
- Quels principes éthiques on
aimerait mettre de l'avant...
KnKnKnKnKnKnoppers s'intéresse
surtout aux questions éthiques
entourant la génétique.
BARTHA KNOPPERS, Centregégégégél
- Les discussions éthiques
ont vraiment commencé avec la
naissance de Louise Brown, avec.
Louise Brown, c'était les
gamètes de ses deux parents,
mais on imaginait toutes sortes
de possibilités, les dérives
et où étaient les balises.
- En 2018, ces balises sont
remises en question lorsque
He Jiankui annonce avoir créé
les premiers bébés génétiquement
modifiés. Le chercheur chinois
cherchait à immuniser
des jumelles contre le VIH.
Devant le tollé international,
il finit en prison.
- Ça a choqué tout le monde,
un peu comme Dolly, parce
qu'on ne pensait pas y arriver.
On parle toujours : il faut
prévenir, éviter, penser
d'avance et tout ça et tout
à coup, bang! Le lendemain,
dans le journal, on ouvre
et on dit : "Oh non,
c'est arrivé, c'est ici!"
- Pour la Dr Knoppers, il faut
un consensus international
pour éviter de tels dérapages.
- Ce n'est plus un phénomène
d'un pays, ou d'une nationalité,
ou d'une science.
- Depuis 2004, il est illégal de
cloner un être humain au Canada.
Il aura fallu 10 ans de débats
pour arriver à cette loi.
Mais depuis, la réglementation
n'a pas évolué.
(bêlement)
Il faudra probablement attendre
la prochaine grande découverte
qui captivrererererererere
collectif.
Ici Yasmine Mehdi,
Radio-Canada, M